by the way by the way first unicorn
officially today
one of my angel investments officially
raised at over a billion dollars
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
all right everyone we have uh a great
episode but first before we get into it
i've got a huge
favor um there's this new feature in the
itunes store
um so i want to show it to you i want to
be one of the first to use it so go
type in my first million or hopefully
you're already if you're not if you're
on an android you can ignore this for
now or you got
no a matter of fact you can do this for
spotify so go to your itunes store right
now
um or your podcast app my apologies
podcast app type in my first million and
find our podcast and then you're going
to see a button
it should be blue on a podcast and it
says
subscribe click that button and
something really amazing is going to
happen and
i want you to tweet at me the sampar
with a picture of that
and uh we're gonna you're gonna see this
brand new feature that apple just for
launch it's
it's a really cool hack that we just
discovered so click that button and tell
us what's happened
this is what they were talking about in
the keynote yesterday right yeah it's
like a big deal only a few people got
access to it i knew a guy
and i got access to it so go ahead and
click that subscribe button and if
you're in spotify
uh i talked to daniel l he actually
they're releasing something too click
the button that says
daniel the cousin of daniel eck the
actual founder of spotify right
it's their cousin it's a norwegian thing
or
uh you know uh swedish thing whatever he
is it's a scandinavian thing
um anyway today we've got a great
episode sean who do we have we had
elaine zelby on she's a vc at signal
fire
and um more importantly she is an ideal
woman so she
has a sub stack that's three new ideas
every week uh very much like what we do
she also does this thing called
i don't know what it's called but it's a
podcast about boring businesses like
unsexy it's called unsexy
unsexy it's about like you know oh you
run a chemical plant tell me about that
you know so things like that so
very much uh in line with what we do we
had a bunch of
uh we brainstormed a bunch of ideas so
we talked about ideas
the adulting vault we'll tell you what
that is um the smoo
sleep uh sleep bed for adults uh
therapunch was one of the ideas a
subscription shoe company idea
and um and there we go that's one with
the the startup sas bundle that was the
best startup sas bundle and also she
kind of gave us a peek under the hood
signal fire has this thing
that's like a this data machine that
spits out like you know
great investments using all the 27
different data signals
and we were kind of asked her like hey
is that [__] is that just marketing
seems like it's just marketing is that
[__] and uh she gave a pretty good
response so we kind of talked about that
as well
all right we're gonna get to the episode
but first remember go to the uh
the podcast store click that button that
says subscribe and then you have to send
me a picture on twitter the sampar
and you're gonna see this new feature
that apple released i promise it's gonna
be worth it so make sure everyone
does it right now thank you so elaine
hey what's going on uh i'm sam parr
we haven't met i think you were on the
podcast before when i was
sick um so sam last time she was on she
had one idea that
well two ideas one that went kind of
like semi-viral that was the
milk bombs idea of like a functional
milk bomb
uh i don't know if you even know what
that means like yeah you get the
you get that the picture basically you
dunk a little like a bath bomb you
dunk it into your milk and it sort of
has a little fizzy color whatever
experience and you're adding some uh
some adaptogen adaptogen
people like that one a lot but now that
we have like these viral video
people oh it would be on a whole nother
level now
yeah should we ask her to yeah is that
like that's like a pretty virally thing
but sorry go ahead we'll do that
and the other one i really liked was um
fantasy football for stocks
so basically creating a little game like
let's say we could create a game me
you andrew whoever and um we each
get our a budget we we allocate it into
a portfolio that you
you get to change it every month or so
and then we see whose portfolio would
have performed the best like fantasy
football
where you get points based on the you
know the ups and downs of the stock so
a very social you're not actually
investing it doesn't have to be real
money
a very social way to be gambling or
betting on on stocks what do you think
of that one sam
i used to do that as a kid didn't we do
that as a kid in like class
there was a thing back in like seventh
grade i think everybody did this one
fantasy portfolio for like a month at
school
and uh but it hasn't it was it was
pretty rudimentary then and it never
made its way
out so i think somebody who worked at
yahoo fantasy football
they should just basically fork
everything they learned about how to
make
yahoo fantasy football viral and be like
cool i'm gonna do that except instead of
you know the patriots it's gonna be you
know amazon and tesla and whatnot
did you folks um have you guys used
uh is it called the they were one of our
sponsors
uh was it weeble what's the israel
israeli coinbase competitor
israeli coinbase israeli yeah
they're yeah one of those words is wrong
uh
coinbase it's an exchange crypto yeah
yeah well it's
but they um i think it's weeble um
but they have this feature so basically
it's like a stock investing platform i
know about
we bull like bull yes yeah
yeah yeah is that the one but anyway
they have this feature where they have
this thing where
you can sign up and you can choose to
share your portfolio with anyone
and people can copy you and i thought
that was kind of amazing
uh it's kind of like turns and you like
invest in their fund
and i don't even think they make any
money off of it but it's just like
there's a bunch of these that came out
in the last i don't know two years
elaine
you've probably seen all of them public
came out as like one of the
robin hood competitors where it's like a
social network a social feed where you
can see what people are investing in
then there's the more extreme versions
like what you're talking about like uh
doji i think is one of them
and in doji i create kind of like my
little basket of stocks and i call you
know the sean index
and you could just straight up buy the
sean index and you can invest in all my
stocks and i get kind of like
it's like my index becomes more popular
because you've
invested in it and you trust me and it
like shows that you follow it or you
invested in it
well in 2017 so eric voorhees who was
the guy that created shapeshift he
actually created satoshi dice he was
super super early in the crypto space
he launched something that never got out
of private beta called prism
and you could create a basket of tokens
this is when all the altcoins started
popping up on ethereum
and you could show so it could be you
know sean's basket of tokens and sams
and you could watch and i could follow
you
and i could just invest in your basket
of tokens but it was a competition too
and i thought it was such a great idea
i'm not sure why it never got off the
ground
but it was cool i digged it can i ask
you elaine what is signalfire i'm on
your website
um like your landing page
is i want whatever you're selling but
i'm still a little confused as to what
it is
so we do that a little bit on purpose we
are a venture capital firm
but we're actually structured and
operate a lot more like a technology
company
so if you look at our team we're about a
third engineers and data scientists
building products
we're about a third people on our
platform these are the in-house business
people doing
pr recruiting growth and then we have
investment
and we you know we essentially monetize
via the investment vehicle
and we're currently investing on our fun
three which is 500 million dollars but
you know we're not we don't have capital
in the name we don't have ventures in
the name we definitely try to be a
little bit more startupy than the
traditional vc
so but are you using like on your web
page on the
landing page it's like you guys use some
type of data to spot trends
is that is that so we buy scrape
or you know aggregate every data signal
you could possibly imagine and our
engineers have proprietary algorithms
that use that data
to do one of two things one we have
different systems that are alerting
systems for us on the investment side
so they pull in all these signals and
they try to show us at seed at series a
and at series b
who are the cool companies what should
we be looking at and also trends around
markets and things like that fundraising
trends
and then we have a bunch of products for
the portfolio around talent migration
talent movement who's good who's in
market from a
hiring perspective competitive intel
co-spend analysis
market intel all that kind of stuff do
you so like when a lot of people
like when sean and i probably have both
started our things
um which like granted by the way by the
way first unicorn officially today
my one of my angel investments
officially raised at over a billion
dollars
although i gotta say it's not super
exciting because
it's a company i was trying to invest in
from the seed but at this point i wasn't
like a
and i was running my company i wasn't
like i was i only wanted to invest i
thought it was a great idea and i like
the founder
but i like forgot to follow up and then
like oh i followed up he's like oh dude
we closed that like two months ago
sorry i'll get you in the a and then
when the a came around it was like oh
dude it's super competitive sorry i'm
not gonna be able to get you in
so finally he messaged me he was like
hey man i'm gonna make sure i get you in
this time i feel like i
i [__] you over you know once you
missed it the first time
we're definitely gonna get you in here
in the i don't know the b
yeah the b round at a 200 million
valuation i was like bro 200 million
i knew you when you were a baby here
this was this is way too high all right
[__] it i'm in
and so uh that company is now worth over
company
um i don't know if i could well we'll
say i might i might bleep it out
come on you have to tell we may have to
bleep it out because he may not have
announced it yet but it's a company
called deal
and they do my husband and i were
talking about that one this morning
yeah okay what were you guys talking
about my first unicorn because
i appreciate that yes the joke is
this is essentially a company i wanted
to build three years ago
and i started seeing every startup that
had
10 employees was starting to hire
internationally and they had to treat
them as contractors
and there was no way to manage it and if
i looked under the hood
most companies were using shield geo as
the peo and everyone hated it
super old school so i was like okay
somebody needs to go and build a better
shield geo
under the hood do kind of the plaid
model of building the nitty-gritty going
into each country
that people in the us hire remotely with
and build out the you know
infrastructure go and find every startup
and say hey we're going to handle all
the hiring the payroll compliance
everything for your remote people i love
it i think it's such a good idea
wait so what sorry how do you spell it
sean d e e
i think the url is let'sdeal.com unless
they change i think they got deal.com
also now
oh cool so i actually use it uh that's
how i pay
kind of like any contractors that i work
with even if they're in the us
i'm like oh this is way easier because i
just type in their name i say what the
contract is every month i'm going to pay
them this at the first of the month it's
like
would you like an mda with that i'm like
yeah why not let's add on an nda
they're like great would you like to add
a milestone based payment i'm like you
know what that's a good idea i do like
milestone-based payments
that's that aligns our incentives it's
like boom here's a contract we've
sent it to them when they'll sign it
it'll be kept in your records
automatically for you
we took care of all the the compliance
and tax issues that you're gonna have to
deal with based on where they live
and um we'll connect to your bank and
then it'll auto pay every month for
for you and send you an invoice when
you're done and i was like oh wow that's
great you just eliminated the need for
me to have like a person who does that
whole thing
by the way it's on their page that
they've just raised money at a billion
dollar
uh valuation so their biggest
competitors so there's two big ones
papaya global and remote.com
and deal started out a little bit
differently the other two said hey we're
going to really focus on full-time
employment
internationally they focused on
contractors and they've had to shift
from my understanding a little bit
because
in reality you don't just have
contractors for the most part and you
want
one-stop shop you want to go and have
different solutions for the different
types of employees right so i think they
now have everything
exactly that's everything they also let
you like pay in crypto and pay in
every currency and like you know they're
do they're doing all those kind of
gnarly problems
which is great uh i almost invested in
remote.com also i really like that guy
uh his
his name is job uh the guy who's like
this founder i think it's pronounced
something like slightly different but
it's j-o-b
and i just like i love that whenever
it's like usain bolt is the fastest man
in the
in the world i'm like this guy named job
is is creating the platform for hiring
remote workers like okay
i'm in i'm interested and he was like
interested in this company deal
uh as soon as i heard the idea i was
like oh yeah that's a pain point like
that's a real pain point and i don't
know how people solve it but if
i look i went to their website i saw it
was like it's real similar i'm not that
sophisticated right it's like
yes this is a real problem then i go to
your website and i'm like oh you're one
of the easy to use
products which is like just kind of the
standard best practices of design and
like
clear like good colors good font clear
copy
two clicks and you're done and i was
like oh yeah this is gonna win
and so then i started um hitting up the
founder and i met with them and i was
like oh this is amazing let's let's do
something and then like
unfortunately you know this would have
been a much much bigger return
had i just been like a little bit more
proactive about following up before but
you know
i feel like i've learned that lesson 30
times you invested ten thousand dollars
in them let's say
um would that mean that it's worth like
what five times more
well at the current valuation yeah um on
paper
on paper yeah um uh
but if i had done it at the seed it
would have been you know maybe i think
the seed was probably like 10 15 million
um coming out of yc and so you know
that's that's taking 10 million turning
it into a billion
in terms of the multiple uh plus
dilution blah blah blah not that
interesting
more importantly i can now say i
invested in a unicorn so
that's just a stamp that i needed to
collect here
also i appreciate your honesty that you
invested at the b
because so many people will come in at
later rounds and be like i'm in all
these unicorns and they invested in the
previous round
what i wanted to ask though was elaine
so when i started my company
i just was like this seemed like it
could work and it's fun and i'm good at
it i bet
sean kind of did the same i bet where's
like uh yeah it might work
signal fire seems far more um
analytical my question is in reality
do you actually think that that matters
like if i'm trying to start something
do you actually think that the
likelihood that i'm going to succeed by
but if i just said elaine um give me
three things to start
versus i'm just gonna go do whatever is
do you think that
you would let me give you an example
here of like honesty so when i started
my rolling fund
the marketing was i have this big
podcast
that's going to help me get deal flow
and podcast well okay if you have a
podcast that does 5 million downloads a
year
in the business nation startup niche
it's like okay that's a unique asset i
see how you're different than the other
funds
in reality most of my deals don't come
from podcast listeners sending me stuff
or reaching out to me
most of the deals are from the same five
friends who email me when they see
something cool
and like that would have been much less
sexy to talk about like oh i have five
great friends
who will email me cool stuff and i email
them cool stuff but in reality that's
how the best deals happen
and or just like i'm bored on twitter a
lot when i see something cool i reach
out
again doesn't sound that great for my
fund marketing but is
closer to reality so the question is
basically
how often are your deals because you're
like computer programs like
dude this company under value growing
fast nobody's heard of it versus
another fund share something with you or
you guys are interested in space and you
see something cool on product owner or
whatever and you reach out
and then that's how it happens so can
you give us the truth
well so in general venture capital i
have the most commoditized asset you can
imagine that i'm selling i'm selling
money
and so in terms of differentiation you
talking about having this podcast
having a different model and
differentiation does go a long way
but if i break up venture capital into
five stages it's
sourcing so how do i find people
diligencing picking
winning and then supporting and so we
try to leverage
data in probably four of the five
different categories on the sourcing
side we've definitely done deals that
were completely from our
alerting system in addition we just do a
ton more
outbound than the average firm because
we'll go in these meetings and we'll
triage based off of oh this looks
interesting
and oh elaine is connected to the
founder or elaine knows about this
industry you go follow up right
so we do a lot more of that outbound
than traditional is it the majority of
our deals no
on the diligencing side really trying to
understand how good are these people
so giving people you know talent scores
understanding hiring patterns
mobile app downloads alexa score trends
a lot of the stuff you guys look at in
you know the similar web or a-refs or
that kind of stuff we're just doing on a
different level
but i would say where we have the most
value
does that level actually matter so you
you basically said that
you you must listen because we i talk
about aha reps all the time we talk
about similar webs
all the time that's like anyone could do
that for
either free or for 100 a month and it's
like i could just skim it and i kind of
have an idea
you kind of implied that you do that
times 10 or whatever it is
is that way actually better than our way
i think in our industry it does actually
move the needle for us so
give us an example like you know if i'm
watching billions and i'm like oh [__]
bobby actually you know he gets
satellite data and he can see
you know how many trucks are leaving the
factory every day and that's how you
know blah blah blah
i've seen some things in vc where it's
like you know everybody's kind of got
app annie or whatever like
something to look at app growth but you
know i don't know
second measure where you get credit card
spending data aggregated
that can be more interesting or like you
know if you're plugged in with pipe or
somebody you could see recurring revenue
businesses that are growing in some way
before maybe
others do so i'm curious what's a cool
data source that
give me an example like oh we have this
one data source and that helped us spot
this cool company can you
tell a story like that so it's not the
one data source piece it's the fact that
we buy or
have access to all of them and then we
combine them in unique ways
so it's really about the joining of the
data and what that surface is for us
and that could be again on the you know
we we look at things like business
filings and then we combine that with
data on okay well what is their website
what are their app
i can download that you know somebody is
a founder based in san francisco
they just incorporated their company as
a delaware c corp i can then
know when they filed for incorporation i
know who the person is i can put them
through our talent ranking score or our
founder ranking score i can then see who
are they working with how good are those
people
what is the business category how
interesting is that for us
how investable is the timing so we have
a kind of timing
alerting system too those things
combined will then give it a score
and saying okay this one you should look
at versus when you shouldn't based off
of the aggregate score
and that's the piece that i think
actually helps not the single data set
or the single piece of info
you guys have a score can you give me my
founder score what am i
i could but i don't think i'm allowed to
oh come on
what's going on here this is the best
marketing ever for signifiers
i know we do we actually do score uh we
give people ranks it's uh you know one
is like the number one person we think
in our list right now and then it kind
of goes down so
it's like a chess ranking it's like you
know there's like like an elo score
basically or something where
everybody is actually ranked one to one
million or whatever pretty much yeah
exactly and it changes
what's going on no because it's for us
like we only invest see in series a and
series b
so i don't care about people in those
other categories i want to know
who are the best people starting
companies right now that are actively
looking for funding
gotcha that's the timeliness is actually
really important but the thing that's
also really cool about what we can do so
i'll give you a really concrete example
we have a company that is in the shopify
ecommerce infrastructure ecosystem
and they were looking to say hey we want
to go and target i'm going to make these
numbers up but we want to target
every merchant who has between 10 and
100 million dollars in revenue
in these four categories and here are
three buyer titles
oh and like here here's where they need
to be located we can go and pull
all that data we match that up to the
people at the company so we say here
their email addresses here are the
people you should go after
after and we create this kind of custom
lead list for them and so
being able to do that really really
really that's on the support the company
said
so and you guys sell access to this
platform right like this is a product no
yeah no that's one i was gonna ask you
because why i mean i bet you can make uh
like 50 to 100 million dollars a year in
um
bernie told me that you guys are
spinning this out or considering
spinning this out as a product
we do not sell it and we don't spin it
out that's part of our whole selling
point is that this is within the family
so if you come and take our money and
become part of the signal fire family
you get access to all this stuff so we
don't actually give it out outside of it
interesting okay who uh
who came up with this so our founding
partner chris farmer
has a long history in the vc world and
he kind of got frustrated saying
why are we investing in these bleeding
edge tech companies and we're literally
doing deals by talking to our friends
kind of what shawn was alluding to and
so he's like look
we have access to all this data why are
we not leveraging it and so he had kind
of spun this out in his last firm
and then created an entire fun cycle
around it and a firm
around it yeah i'm going to say i still
think it's 50
marketing and 50 useful but that's
higher than it was
in my head an hour ago where i would
have said it's 90 percent just marketing
and 10 useful so you've done a good job
you've moved he's right elaine
40 please say that again is he right in
terms of
what it is uh i would say more useful
than not
for sure especially i think the two
areas i would say it's on the barbells
it's definitely useful on the flagging
sourcing companies that we would never
have seen
and it's very very useful on the
supporting side and honestly we're
as i mentioned before you know we kind
of like say we're a startup we do okrs
we measure nps score we kind of treat
ourselves like a
tech startup in terms of how we operate
and so for us we care so much about our
nps
we care so much about are we moving the
needle for founders
so if we can be you know if that's the
only place that it's really valuable
that's that's enough
you know that's that's really enough
right now did you ever hear about
chamoth's uh eight ball
yeah yeah this sort of reminds me of
that yeah go get this is this is going
to be a clip i tell go for it
uh yeah so so chamath who was you know
founder of social capital or is the
founder social capital
at one point in time was like look we uh
he came from facebook
super data driven growth team he was
like leading the growth team helped
grow it from whatever 100 million users
to a billion users and he was like well
why don't we have that same level of
analytical rigor when it comes to our
companies
and sort of as that thought evolved it
came down to something really simple he
goes
let's make capital as a service uh
instead of
you know software service capital as a
service so here's how it goes it's
self-serve
you come and you plug in your analytics
our
little algorithm will run a formula and
it'll basically tell you two things
it'll say
here's how you rank relative to other
sas companies that are your size your
age
in your kind of like price point or your
demographic and then
so you'll know if you're above the
benchmark if your retention is way
better or way worse than other companies
and then secondly they were like this is
our moneyball formula to basically
figure out if we should invest in you or
not
and um and so that they hyped it and as
a founder it was a little bit scary
right you're going to go
am i going to give to moth like all my
data basically
pipe right into our database and just
say hey here you go and it feeds their
system right because whether they invest
in us or not
they've just downloaded hey at this
point in time here's how this company
was doing and then they take your
historical data as well
so it's like they sucked in all this
data so that
if they looked at the hustle they'll
know whether they should invest in the
hustle but also
morning brew and the skim and any other
company like the hustle they'll be able
to compare and contrast
and as a founder it's useful because you
want to compare and contrast but you've
just
uh you know you've opened up your blouse
to tichimoth and i think that that was
for me a little bit scary but i think um
some people really liked it
and ultimately i think it was more
marketing than than substance i don't
know elaine
what's the word on the street but like i
don't see them using it anymore i know
that
the group of people that spawn off of
chamoth like uh
arjun and those guys from tribes i think
they still do that or that's a big piece
of it they don't maybe brand it that way
but
um i don't know elaine was was that like
was that legit was it as secret saucy as
they tried to make it sound or was it a
little overhyped
i was never on the inside so i have no
idea i know that it was very polarizing
in terms of what you were saying some
founders loved it some founders hated it
in my opinion it only works at certain
stages and in certain categories this
does not work at all at the seed stage
you're betting on people for the most
part and you're betting on the growth of
a category
there's no data there's nothing that's
going to give me by the way most
startups don't have their data
structured enough or in a way that you
can actually like run these types of
to apples analysis until you're ready
clear bank clearbank makes sense to me
because you're literally saying hook
into my facebook and google data
there's nothing that i could be yeah and
there's nothing i can be fudging around
that
i'm gonna go analyze it and say you put
in 10 to facebook you get out 15. i'm
going to give you a short term high
interest loan
it works for everybody we win people are
now doing this for amazon sellers and to
your point shopify
so on amazon it's much more around
working capital so
people are constantly in these
manufacturing cycles where cash flow
negative
so they're like okay well i can hook
into your amazon seller
portal i can see exactly what your you
know inflow and outflow of money is i
can hook into your bank account
i should be able to do dynamic loans so
i'm never
at peak you know peak exposure from a
loan perspective for very long
i'm kind of like constantly pulling it
in and pulling it out that makes a ton
of sense to me
yesterday i invested in a c stage
company and i pretty much only did it
because sean did it
um i basically i was like i think this
is silly are you
in he goes i'm in i i if you don't want
to go in ask him if i could have your
your i was like i love it and he's like
yeah i don't know i think i hate it i
was like what's there to hate it's
amazing
and then he's like yeah it's so good
that i kind of hate just popular things
it seems so
good and i was like that's the stupidest
thing i've ever heard i said if you
don't want it
give me your share and because i was
asking the founder for more it was hypey
it was hypey it's got all the cool kids
in it and i'm like oh all the cool kids
are doing it i don't want to do it
but sean was like well i'm doing it and
i talked to the guy and the guy seemed
wonderful
and i really don't even know can we talk
about the company now or do we need to
talk about it next episode so that
there's a little distance between this
combo and that
uh yeah yeah i guess okay it's called
synthesis do you know this one no what
do they do ah
the algorithm didn't spot it but
hey the uh five friends did did uh did
spot this all right so this is a cool
company so the
uh the story of this is have you heard
of ad astra which is like
elon musk's personal school that was
inside spacex so for those who don't
know
elon musk you know he's ceo of spacex
the ceo of tesla
two kind of like multi multi-billion
dollar companies and um
his kids were going to school he
basically needed to have his kids be in
school and he kind of was like you know
the traditional school system is not so
great
why don't we build a school inside
spacex that's um
done the way we think and his his big
kind of like theory was
in schools they teach you um like here's
this tool right like let's say calculus
or algebra right like
here's algebra go learn algebra but they
don't tell you kind of like why you need
to know algebra right like maybe
they should be teaching you how to you
know run a lemonade stand
and in order to calculate how many
lemons you're going to need per day
boom we'll teach you algebra that's a
tool to help you do this thing you
wanted to do so his
his big thing was why don't we teach
kids how engines work rather than how
what a wrench is uh as like a basic
analogy and so he creates this
the school um or he wants to have the
school and he creates it and there's a
guy i think josh is his name
he runs the school at spacex it's great
it's kind of like well known and
the kind of the fundamental premise was
kids were learning by
by really but like playing games and so
uh have you guys seen the movie ender's
game
yes so in ender's game you basically
you're in small teams of kind of kids
and then you go into one like simulation
area where you're gonna you know your
teammate fights against team b and c and
um the game always has like
some kind of like arbitrary set of rules
but it teaches you like strategy
and teamwork and communication and like
all the different things you need to do
to win the game and so um kids love it
because they play
it's it's competitive it's like doing
not just sitting there listening to a
lecture
and so anyways those are the same
principles they took into this so let's
say they
they'll create a game that's like i
don't know um
it's about art right so instead of
telling you okay here we're going to
talk about art so
sit down and read these three chapters
about you know
the renaissance period of italy and
memorize it
no instead they'll create like a map
it's like okay where do you want to
explore
and then you pick you're like japan you
go to japan and you find this artifact
and then you have to bid on it and the
other teams are bidding on it too
are you trying to decide should we bid
on this well let's go look at it let's
go look at italy let's see what they
have there and the team goes and
all these kids are playing this together
on zoom anyway so it's it's this really
cool
totally different alternative like form
of education
and so what ended up happening was the
guy who created this at spacex for
elon and his kids um the game system was
called synthesis and what he did was
they spun it out with elon's blessing
elon's like hey go for it like
yeah this more kids should have access
to this and he paired up with this guy
who was like the number one engineer at
class dojo so he had been working at an
edtech company signalfire is an investor
this is our portfolio company and so
they got together and they created this
this company synthesis
and they um okay i guess can't share too
much of their numbers but they have this
amazing traction so far
you know business is only six to eight
months old they spent zero dollars on
paid marketing all the
attention has come because of free press
and people who are reading about elon
school and just
sort of click the links and find them
and it's gotten the greatest headline
ever which is like
elon musk spinning off school right and
the defender was very honest he was like
you know honestly like we had a big
question like does this only work if
it's rocket scientist
kids right because like maybe they are
willing to like
really engage in this material and
figure it out and play these things like
but is this accessible if your dad is
not a you know a rocket scientist at
spacex
uh or your mom is not like a you know
data scientist or uh wherever
and so um but they found that you know
it does and so they have like
super high retention amazing uh revenue
already in six months
uh you know doing multiple millions of
dollars a year in revenue with zero
dollars
paid marketing and what seems like the
perfect team it's the guy who created
the school
at elon's thing and this guy from class
dojo and so i was like what's not to
love
great impact super cool product i want
to send my own kids there
great traction in a very short amount of
time and like tons of room to grow
because they haven't even started
marketing yet and so i was like i love
it and sam was like yeah like it seems
really great but i'm skeptical of real
things that everything every
everything's
expensive it was expensive well can i
pitch you a spin on this that i wrote
about recently and you can
you can give this to the guys because it
might be interesting for them so
i wrote about a concept of doing this
but on top of roblox
and the reason being roblox already has
the eyeballs and the attention of kids
75 of kids between 9 and 15 i think
are on roblox and today you know anybody
can go and build these games
but why can't you go and build games i
was focusing more on life skills
so things like financial literacy which
you never learn
mental health which you never learn all
the things that you'd want either a
younger kid or a teenager to learn
gamify it but build it where they're
already there and also
enable the kids to become the builders
so partner with some people like these
two people doing synthesis
bring in some kids to make it actually
appropriate and age appropriate
and then let them have some of the
upside and let them spin off the games
and bring in their millions of followers
but i think there's something to be done
on top of roblox
yeah i love that i think um that works
for two reasons one
is you can if you okay teaching kids
through games not a new idea like when i
was a kid i was playing math blaster and
what you know whatever else these little
games on whatever you know
we had a computer room at my house and i
used to go there and get to play an hour
a day
and um so you know teaching kids through
games obviously been around for a while
but now the games are already built with
tons of love uh
kids already know the controls like in
fortnite or roblox they already know how
to play they're already super familiar
with it they already love the game
and so and they also have now created
roblox and fortnite have these like kind
of open field
open world systems where you can go
build whatever the hell you want and
just share
the link and so it makes total sense to
me to borrow
the millions of dollars they poured into
their game engine and the marketing
um and the distribution where they
already have kids with accounts
to just say now all we have to build is
the learning experience
and um and so i think that is a a great
idea
can i they might be able to port it over
you know they can port some of these
games to roblox
can i ask you about something you wrote
about and see so you have elaine has a
sub sack uh
uh zell is it what's zelby.subsec.com
three things that's just my last name
um it's it's cool uh it's a lot like
this podcast you basically put out three
kind of business ideas a week right is
that the idea exactly i write about
three requests for startups or
opportunities i see to build
big businesses and like how i would do
it how i would monetize it and why now
great so obviously everyone should go
sign up for that because it's
it's right at this r alley um i think
i've seen you because you've linked to
us a couple once or twice and i've like
tracked the traffic back um all right so
you have this thing called startup sas
bundle
and i wanted to bring this up because i
think that most
everyone listening is in the world where
they can actually go out and start this
i think that i've actually investigated
this a ton so
i i have or i don't own it anymore but
we used to own this thing called the
hustle so we had like two million
subscribers
of many of which are like these
businessy folks and i'm like oh we
should make this and sell it
there's actually a lot of reasons i
think why this can't work at a huge
scale
but i think there's a bunch of reasons
why it could work at like a i think you
could build a five to ten million dollar
a year company
in like three to four years pretty
straightforward can can you talk about
your uh ideas here and you can actually
tell me if you think i'm wrong or right
yeah and i'll tell you why i think it's
way bigger than that right so
the idea here is if you look at the
average series a company
they're using i think the status 34
different sas applications
and what happened was we used to have
these monoliths which are sap
and oracle and i used to joke like bring
back sap and i don't really mean that
but what i mean is i am so sick of now
having to deal with 34 vendors
34 uis 34 logins and passwords
you know 34 different bills and renewal
cycles and all that kind of stuff it
just makes no sense
and if you think about what core
business software runs a startup it's
very consistent
you have things like you need g suite or
office 365
you need some kind of communication tool
you need something for payroll
for hr for accounting for recruiting
for like crm marketing project
management
issue tracking and help desk like those
to me that is the core
of business software and of course
they're best in breed
for all these things at the smb level
the mid market level the enterprise
level
but in reality if you're a startup that
is seed series a
probably even getting into series b you
need like
not the 80 20 rule but like 60 of the
functionality
and that's the easier stuff to build the
additional bells and whistles
are the harder pieces and those aren't
even utilized by these early companies
so the idea is look okay if you wanted
to build a bundle
and get people to migrate over if
they've already bought eight different
pieces of software that's nearly
impossible
but if you catch people when they have
nothing and you're gonna say hey
we have this out of the box bundle you
can start with three modules
but as you go and you want a crm because
you didn't have a sales team before
just add on the crm module it already
hooks in it's super seamless it has the
same user experience no new login no new
vendor relationship
and you kind of continue to add to the
bundle as your needs evolve
and break this down though is you said
something important that we have to go
back to
you said something you said it won't
work if you already are using something
yes can you explain why because that's
actually a really big deal
yes ripping and replacing software is so
painful and it's incredibly hard to get
people to do it
you've already trained your team on it
it has all of your information and data
sitting in that system
it's just really hard to rip something
out when it's there which is why
things like salesforce are gazillion
dollar companies
even though people complain about it all
the time it's that is your system of
record for that thing
so i think that the vendor won't give
you
what let's call this elaine company
elaine elaine bundle company
they're not going to give a lane bundle
company a referral fee i think for
correct
and the whole way this makes money i
mean i guess there's two way a
subscription or a referral fee
their sales force is going to say uh no
these customers already use us we're not
going to like give you any more discount
or we're not going to give you a
let me clarify so so you're not saying
it's not class pass it's not saying
pay me x and then you get discounts
across all your 34 apps what you're
saying is
make a beginner version of the core
eight things
as a as an actual bundled thing not the
single player apps our single
function apps and do the 80 20 and just
do the core functionality don't get the
the long tail of like edge case features
that you need
and offer it to somebody out of the box
as like hey here's the simple thing so
you don't need to sign up for 12
different services
yes and when you look at the volume of
companies at the early stage
versus the later stage which need
enterprise functionality
the volume is like 1000x at the early
stages
so in terms of your ability to capture
those people and capture them early
where they are going to be sticky
and they're going to grow with you to a
point will people outgrow this
maybe but the number of people that ever
get to that scale are so
few and far between that i just don't
think it matters right and i think
people have to acquire those customers
early on
we work with um a lot of people who
advertise with the hustle and all their
whole like we're uh one of them is
called just works you know what just
listen
yeah this works is basically a i'm gonna
kind of
dumb it down really dumb but it's
basically a payroll software but
because of the way that they operate you
have to sign up with them pretty much
from the beginning like right when you
start a company
and i have a feeling that they're
struggling because they can't get
it's really hard to get a lot of those
people to sign up for you so
challenging in the same way in the same
way it's hard for
signal fire in order to find companies
who are just starting it's really really
hard for these folks well so here's my
hack and i learned this
so back in the days when i was first
getting into startups
i got really into growth hacking back in
like 2013 when it was a really hot topic
and i started my own side hustle
consulting gig working with seed and
series a founders on growth
and i learned really quickly that if i
partnered with the
vcs they would just send me unlimited
number of customers i never did
any business development because they're
constantly investing in net new seed and
series 8 companies
and they're trying to be helpful and
their companies 100
of companies are needing help with
growth 100 and so they're like
okay who should we send them to send
them to elaine so
the hack here is you start with all the
vcs so
they're getting i get asked a dozen
times a week
what software should i buy for this what
tool should i use for that
so that's my hack to get started then
you start to get some viral word of
mouth going among founders because
founders have their groups online they
have their communities they talk
they're saying oh dude you have to get
this like that's the best software you
can use for all your stuff
so that's how i would go to market even
then like where you were
growth hacker growth comes right after
growth comes after you have a team you
have a product you have something right
you start to talk about growth
whereas yeah even when you talk to a vc
you've already done something you
usually are not like
there is precede where it's like just
you know two people not an idea
but um it is still hard to catch you
before you've even started with slack
and g
suite and uh you know three of those
eight eight modules you know
my whole thing around so the one thing
everyone will have
is either g suite or office 365 that i'm
not trying to build right that
you do you do g suite and this hooks
into that i'm not trying to kind of take
that down
you know slack yes probably that one is
a little bit easier in my opinion to rip
out
but if i look at our seed portfolio and
when they graduate to series a
that is the time when they're starting
to think about getting a crm helper
marketing automation system and that's i
think there's probably three different
pieces of software that are the right
insertion points
after you get g suite the next thing is
probably payroll and if you look
gusto is kind of like the only thing
most people use today
it's been around for a long time it does
find i don't think it's a particularly
super super complex piece of software so
can you go and say cool if you're under
40 employees we offer the exact same
functionality as gusto but we also offer
xyz and you know
zillion workshops you have a bunch of
ideas let's hop to another idea um that
you have give us like
give us your top three ideas and we'll
pick which one to go into so just give
us the one liner
someone should start this i i i that's
cool if you think that's going to be
huge i think it won't be huge i think
it'd be mild but i think
one of us could be wrong but either way
it's a win yes agreed
i think it could be huge but even if
it's not it will definitely not be a it
will not be a bad outcome
right oh man where to start okay uh
one that i really like that i also
really want somebody to build
is an adulting vault is this one yeah
what does that mean what's an adulting
fault
so by the time you're out of college
you have a bunch of things in your life
that are like okay i have a
credit card i need to get my first
apartment so i'm paying rent
i have to think about insurance i need
to have all my monthly bills paid
in subscriptions i now have internet and
utilities and all these things are
disparate
and there is no one place where kind of
all of my adulting responsibilities
live and if i compare this to a product
that's existed in the past
mint.com which i think launched back in
was kind of the first thing that said
hey your financial life and financial
picture is sitting all over the place
can i aggregate it
in a really simple app to give you that
one-stop shop and i want to do that for
literally everything
in your adulting world and as you get
older and as you have kids and a
mortgage
and a car and all these other things you
have so many different places where you
know your insurance policies live
your bills live your financial products
live your investing accounts live
and nothing has aggregated that and i
also want it to suggest things that i'm
missing
so it's like hey you might want to think
about life insurance here are the best
life insurance policies for somebody
that fits your description
so you monetize via referral and you
know via affiliate
but it also can let you know of like hey
this is coming up for renewal make sure
you pay this bill and you can auto pay
and stuff like that
can i niche this down even a little bit
more so sure
do you own a house i own a condo um so i
just bought
uh i know sean did i just bought my home
recently it's the first time i've done
it i didn't know anything about anything
i probably still don't
but they gave me so basically what you
do is for anyone who doesn't own a home
uh right before you agree to buy it and
then someone you hire an inspector
in texas i paid this guy only five
hundred dollars was pretty crazy he
comes through and he pokes his head in
the closets and he goes all right
all the electrical things work this
thing it looks like there's a little
mold here yada yada yada
and i got a booklet that was pretty
thick about a 50 page to 100 page
booklet
and i'm like okay that's kind of cool
but even
two months after they did this thing i'm
like wait what is this
light switch this light switch doesn't
turn anything on what is this doing
and in the booklet this guy has actually
already addressed this
um but i don't want to search this like
this like actually
printed out booklet um i almost switched
so you're almost talking like a life
manual
i would niche that down even further i'm
like someone should just create a house
manual so i can just do ctrl f
uh bedroom back corner light switch what
is that where's that what's that doing
um i almost wish i had this just for a
home and then you could layer [__] on
top of that like
uh what's the best home insurance which
i was trying to figure out what's about
you know similar to that
so i i'm with you uh elaine on the
adulting thing
i have two ways to contribute to this
idea one is how do you get customers
i'm a big fan of quizzes quizzes i think
are extremely overlooked
um i remember uh michael burch who was
my investor my previous company and he
was the original founder of bebo and he
he basically had sold he created a
social network he sold it to tickle
which was a quiz company
and tickle was like a 100 million dollar
company that was just doing quizzes like
what breed of dog are you
what um you know what city would you be
if you were a city
that sort of thing like fun little
quizzes and then they had some quizzes
that were career quizzes that would help
you get jobs
and that's like where they made some
money and then when he left there he was
like all right i'm gonna start another
social network and he's like
i know how i'm gonna seed it i'm gonna
make a quiz and he created the best
friends quiz which was
how well do you know me and um and so i
would create a quiz i would answer a
bunch of questions about me then i would
send it to my friends say
take this quiz see how well you know me
and then the results were posted on my
profile
and he got a million members in nine
days uh off this quiz
and their profiles were filled because
they filled in a 10 20 question
in a questionnaire about themselves so
now they had a full profile and they had
their friends
um it was crazy and so i've started to
pay attention to quizzes
i think you could create the adulting
quiz and go viral like kind of now of
like
you know what percent adult are you
because i think most people in our
generation kind of admit and acknowledge
and laugh at the fact that we're like
totally not adults even though our age
technically classifies us as one
and um and so i think you could i think
you use a quiz
to get a bunch of people to just see
like you know do you have life insurance
like yes no i don't [__] know you
know like
what is life insurance right like
exactly one is life insurance
exactly and at the end of it you
basically give them this little
infographic that's like nine squares
and the nine squares are like cool you
have like enough savings
for like three months of life if you
needed it uh good
you've checked that box of adulting um
you don't have
like health insurance you know you are
an ex here click here and we can help
you figure out like why you need this
how much it costs how you should do it
depending on who you are
and so i think you could kind of give
people a report card and then
let them click in to like solve that
problem for themselves and give them the
you know educational referrals that they
need from there
i love that idea also you hit on an
interesting stat that i heard before
which was validated by a couple
companies i was looking at that the
longer the quiz
the more likely people will actually
continue to answer convert
100 that's crazy
when people so for the hustle we get
like 10 000 sign a day
and we would ask them like question
after they sign up and we would do like
i would put two questions in and then
inevitably everyone the company was like
oh that's already too many i'm like no
no no put five and
we put five and then we put ten and
eventually we had like
30 questions and it had like a 98
percent completion rate
um the the more quite and not only that
they actually interact with you more
after they've answered this which is
really counter-intuitive and a lot of
like particularly startup people are
like oh you know i don't want to be too
aggressive yadda yadda i'm like no
well here's how it works i've done this
many times tested the same thing many
times because
uh anyways i'll skip the story part but
there's an entertaining also bebo story
from michael birch where he was like
he put a red but i'm not skipping the
story part i'm telling the story he put
a red button on the site for one out of
every 1
000 uh visitors so imagine going to
facebook and just seeing a shiny red
button in the corner for the first time
and you click it and then the whole
screen just went clear and it was like
here's a cat click the cat and you click
the cat it's like this is a bowl of
pasta
don't click the bowl of pasta you
clicked it and and then it's like the
cat's dead we told you not to click the
bowl of pasta
all right click the cap bring it back to
life it was just a stupid thing that he
had a hundred
steps and what he learned what just
doing he just did this for fun just to
mess around
and what he learned was like the first
the first
button you know people will usually
click out of curiosity but you'll lose
like 30 of people who just don't click
it because they're busy they just go do
something else
and then the second one you lose another
maybe like 20-ish percent
and then after that the people who get
to step three like 98
of them will go all the way to the end
because they want to know how this ends
um and we did the same thing for a
charity project where we were raising
money
it was the exact same step 30 lost on
the first fund
20 loss of the second one and then 98
finish the rest
and uh so i've seen this several times
and everybody in your team will tell you
dude this is too long we shouldn't ask
too many things wrong
it works uh get as much as you can
because once they get to step three
question three
they're gonna finish no matter how many
questions are in the thing
one nuance here that is a hundred
percent accurate for consumer
and 100 inaccurate for b2b for anything
enterprise
shorter is better but i think on the
consumer side i think there's two
psychological things at play
one people love talking about themselves
and that's why we do all the quizzes but
the second which i think sam was hitting
on is
if i've answered 30 questions i think
what i'm going to get
after that is going to be super valuable
right because you know me now
so whatever it's going to be
personalized can be valuable and it
totally works
what do you do at signalfire i saw your
title
is it just venture partner uh i'm a
partner so i
invest but i also spend about 30 percent
of my time
leading all the growth and go to market
programs for the portfolio
so it's kind of just me getting to
exercise that muscle still sometimes i
parachute in parachute out help them
with some of the growth needs
i have an entire network of freelancers
contractors agencies for everything like
hey i need a
seo content writer or i need a tick tock
video producer
and so i can match make on stuff like
that and we run a bunch of events and
teach people how to do the stuff
and are there like two or three partners
and you're one of them basically
just means you're you're one of the
owners you're you're you're one of the
shot callers
i have investment power we'll put it
that way yes i think there are five
partners at signal fire
absolutely let's do ideas sam no nobody
cares about vc uh all right uh well no
wait wait
are you going somewhere with this
compliment which is you're like i'm
looking through these
ideas you're like you're very amazing
uh every one of these ideas is
interesting i want to
go through all of them um and they'll
have me back on we'll do all of them
it'll be great
let's do one right now let's do snoo for
adults what's this one
i know what the snow is because i have a
baby sam does sam do you know what the
snow is
no okay i'll explain this new so there's
a company called the happiest baby and
it produces a smart bassinet
and what it does is rocks the baby it
has noise it can sense all this stuff
and people swear by this shawn did you
guys use this yeah
like my kid is in it right now while i
do the podcast so
uh you know the only reason i can do the
podcast because the snoo is basically
babysitting my kid so like
you see this app and it'll basically say
like oh banks is calm
it's like he's sleeping in there he's
not crying if he cries it'll go to level
two it'll rock more
to try to get him to like chill out so
it saves you the step of going in and
like
soothing the baby
make noise and rock like a human uh and
it's safe
because there's a big like problem with
something called sids but is it is this
new
uh a category or a brand it's a brand
it's a brand it's a brand and these
things are incredibly expensive and you
can only use them for a really short
window of time
and so there's a whole secondary rental
market and resale market for these
things
but parents swear by this so okay let's
apply this to the
broad population of human adults we suck
at sleeping
and nobody has ever rethought sleeping
from a first principle's perspective
i mean first off it kind of makes no
sense that we sleep with another human
in the bed
quite frankly like i roll over i grind
my teeth
you know i we have a dog in our bed too
that kind of makes no sense
second i want something that is
temperature controlled
that rocks me and like knows my my
behavior
that removes all light that removes my
phone so i can't go and scroll on
buzzfeed stupid quizzes at two in the
morning why
has nobody rebuilt the bed for humans
and i think we have enough
sensors we have enough smart connected
home products today
to do this so i would have been i would
buy this i would have been skeptical
about this but for three reasons
a uh i've used the snoo and i'm like oh
i wish i had this like this is great
um b um you've seen a rise in these like
expensive
at-home equipment whether it's peloton
mirror tonal
like there's all these things that cost
like eight sleep bed you know like
things that cost
thousands of dollars that you buy to
improve one small aspect of your life
whereas if you actually like if you told
me there was genuinely a sleep pod
that i could go into that would improve
my sleep by even like 20
what's that really worth to me right
like of course this is kind of a first
world problem high class you know high
class like
product okay whatever yeah it is but um
i think that's worth at least five to
ten grand right because
that's it's eight hours a night every
single night getting better which is
making me healthier happier you know
like
more productive the next day so i
actually now believe that a product like
this
could exist um i never used one of those
google nap
nap pods but like i feel like that's
what those are trying to be
i think i would totally buy it you're
spot on it's a first world problem but
for all the people that are buying 3 000
bikes or like the 5 000 treadmill from
peloton right that's the demographic
here
so i want somebody to build it that's
what peloton should do honestly like
because they're not going to find
another bike
like even the treadmill they're not
going to find another treadmill there's
only so many of these like
places to expand they should go straight
to the bed
and uh and create the bed with a sleep
subscription that's like
the calm sleep stories uh layered on top
of this
well make a wellness brand out of it
health is only one piece sleep is a huge
component of wellness i totally agree
with that
can you talk a little bit about
subscription running shoes because um
that i mean that interests me and i have
a few opinions but
wha what is this so i'm a huge runner i
think you are too sam
and i also have an apple watch most
people who are runners have some kind of
connected device that's tracking all
your steps and things like that
and you're supposed to change your
running shoes every 300 to 500 miles
i have no freaking clue when my shoes
have had 300 to 500 miles i can't even
tell you when i ordered them
also for runners you have a brand and a
style of shoe that you typically stick
with i don't know
any people my running friends who mix
and match so i'm a brooks runner i use
brooks adrenaline
eight and a half narrow every time i
want brooks to create a subscription for
me
it hooks into my watch and my smart my
smart device it says
hey we're just gonna auto order you new
shoes every time you hit like you can
pick
400 you know 400 miles or x number of
months
and it gives me a discount because it
knows i'm gonna be a
customer for my ltv just went up 100x
because it knows i'm gonna continually
order
so a they're going to get me to order
more frequently i'm going to be a super
happy customer because i just get it in
the mail
they can start partnering with other
companies and doing these bundled
subscription products
but to me this is such an obvious
product that no brand's done
you could also partner with some
celebrities and make it really cool i
don't know why this doesn't matter
let me give you the low-tech version of
this um here's how you do this without
the apple watch
yeah you know like toothbrushes have the
little strip the
the little blue strip that's like this
is this toothbrush has like
you know been used way too much and like
i like baby diapers have this too the
blue little streak which tells you they
peed
um this is what you need on the bottom
of the shoe this bottom of the shoe
needs to change
colors as it gets worn out and then
so so you basically have a visual
indicator that you have out worn this
shoe it's time to order another and
[__] it put the promo code for your next
order
under the under the thing so when it
wears away it's like it's time to
reorder here's your code get your next
shoe
here's the problem with that though i
know when my shoes are worn out
my friends know when their shoes are
worn out it's the fact that i have to go
and be proactive and reorder that's the
sticking point
i just want it to happen i mean it's
like the whole amazon button that they
were trying to launch
it's a qr code you just hold your phone
up to the shoe bottom and then it orders
you the next suit
that i like anything to remove friction
i i want all friction removed
i would love to have a package show up
how would this make money i mean because
like if you're when i when i hear this
i'm like yeah okay cool sounds great
but as an outsider i'm like i don't
think i can make money doing this
like brooke why aren't you doing this
this is for brooks this is not i don't
think this is an introduction
i was excited about this i thought you
had an angle here here's an idea
you can obviously bring on doing this
right like correct you can start i mean
if you look
starting at shoe brand i think is like
on the
on the upper five percentile of
horrible ideas i get targeted on social
media by and maybe i must have clicked
on one at some point but
every variation of your all birds type
shoes so like semi-athletic
i mean i've probably seen 50 so it can't
be that hard to make
the only way i think you do this as an
independent company is you provide the
picks and shovels infrastructure for
every brand to do it
so you go and sell to the brooks to the
nikes of the adidas to the reebok i
think that's doable
right uh okay let's see let's pick one
more idea that you have on here what's
the best one
that you sent in that we haven't talked
about yet that you're most excited about
this will be another fun fun one that's
kind of on the consumery side
so i have this concept called therapunch
and i kind of need to give the backstory
here
because this is actually funny and
involves running so there's a nice
tie-in
so like a year and a half ago right
before the pandemic
i was running in the mission in san
francisco at like six in the morning
and it was an area where there was no
people i'm just kind of going
and i have a green light i'm running
through the middle of the street in the
intersection
and this dude in a super beat up janky
car comes and turns right and like cuts
me off
and comes really close to hitting me and
i kind of jump away and gave him the
like what are you doing dude look
and he rolls down his window and starts
screaming out and this is i don't know
if you want to believe this but he's
like
get out of the street you stupid [__]
[__] and
i was like holy [__] and i'm not an
aggressive person
normally but i had had a rough week and
i was kind of on edge anyways
and normally i just turned my head and
run away but i had to take every ounce
of restraint not to go and just
kick the back of his car i was so pissed
i just wanted to punch something
and as i finally got smart and ran away
i was thinking to myself
there's something going on here which
made me want to go and punch his car or
kick his car
and i was like you know everyone always
tells you to go meditate
go download calm go sit in a quiet room
like
great that's fine i need to punch
something and so i wanted to go
punch something and then meditate so the
concept here and i think
now is an interesting time because
there's so much vacant real estate
is you buy up and rage there's so much
rage
rage so much don't forget that part so
much race high demand
well there's also an established uh
concept of these rage rooms smash rooms
break rooms
the problem with these are it's very
dangerous you have to put on a suit
you can hurt yourself there's a lot of
liability and also there's a lot of
cleanup
so this is the exact like low-tech
version it's a
padded room with padded walls punching
bags
things to like rip and pop imagine like
stuffed animals you could tear the heads
off
and you go and you connect to a spotify
rage playlist
and there's a bunch you can choose from
you go in for 15 minutes into one of
these things and if you guys have ever
done boxing
15 minutes you'll be exhausted so you
just get it all out for 15 minutes and
then they take you to the zen zone for
30 minutes
where they have guided meditations and
they have you know spa water and you can
sit and meditate
so you go and get it out then you center
yourself and then you go back to work
sam you're our resident uh rager so uh
how do you feel about this no that would
make me way too mad like i'd be like
[__] time to go to the [__]
thing i just want to smash this [__]
right now
like i smash stuff i i i like like
i do break what's the last thing you've
thrown or broken out of rage
well cell phone i mean i mean everyone
does that do i have my
phone here everyone does not do that i
don't know i haven't done that
my screen is is currently shattered i
mean i just get angry you know
and i do that as well but i i like and a
lot of people tell you not to do that
i think it's great like you're just like
cathartic yeah you're just breaking a
little thing that you could replace with
some money
and like you're not hurting anyone i'll
give you a quick spin on this idea
because i also think that the the
timeliness like i don't want to book and
reserve the room by then
it's all dissipated and now it's a task
i don't want to get it sorry i'm with
sam
you need the instantaneous release um so
so the
other thing i found interesting is
there's a whole bunch of these like
alternative
um alternative therapy things that i
find interesting cryotherapy
where you go in and your your neck is
out of it but your body is in this like
kind of like
i don't even know how low the
temperature goes but it's like this very
cold
like kind of like liquid nitrogen gas
that's put against your body
supposed to be great for recovery
there's the float
franchise which is all about floating in
this like salt water bath where you're
weightless and you're in this
light you know deprived pod and like an
hour goes by and you like hallucinate or
whatever the hell else i don't know joe
rogan talks about it
i have a friend who gave me a pass to go
do this once and so they're awesome
never have you heard of it yeah yeah
there's one in the mission actually i
walk by it all the time
i've been to that one many times and so
there's and then there's basically like
there's a set of these kind of like
alternative things and i wonder if you
could create the equivalent of a gym
membership
that basically says okay instead of
coming to this like a gym membership is
a giant box
that has all the heavy equipment you're
not going to buy for yourself but you
can come here and you can use it
and i wonder if you could do the same if
you bundled these together
where you bundle the different therapies
together sauna steam
cryotherapy float tank whatever and it's
a gym
with no weights and it's a gym basically
for the brain to recover
um and to to relax and uh and you you
put a whole bunch of these things
together
and maybe you create a different type of
uh wellness like category
would you ever do them back to back just
thinking about what those all are would
you ever go
i like what about what about a class
pass for that kind of stuff because
they're pretty niche today and they're
expensive and it's also not
like a gym membership where class pass
had so many problems i could
go into that but i was one of the
earliest users and they lost
so much money on me but ultimately they
were hoping the vendors were hoping that
you'd become a subscriber
but for these things how often are you
going to go to a float tank or cryo spa
or whatever so
if it's more of a one-off thing and you
want to try a bunch of stuff they
could actually end up making money on
that i actually started going quite
regularly i think the difference between
san francisco and where i live now so i
lived in san francisco for eight years
right around the mission
is it's like kind of a pain to get from
a to b you know because you have to take
an uber or a bus a bike or a bike um
although i hated biking in san francisco
um now that i live in austin
i i'll just like it's no big deal to
like leave work at three and then go do
the thing and come back
by and be back by five and get some more
stuff done um and i do these
uh cryotherapy which i don't think does
anything but it's fun
i do the float tank i love all that
stuff so i do think that could actually
people would do that more regularly than
you think
yeah if there's food i think people go
somewhat regularly or like smoothies or
something
i feel like that might work on a side
note and i've looked into the economics
of these things before
very briefly but maybe we should do kind
of a deep dive uh these cryotherapy
like uh places and float tanks places uh
these guys do actually
pretty well like if you just kind of
wanted to if you wanted to buy
essentially a high paying job for
yourself
uh you can you can get a location you
basically buy one of these machines for
three thousand dollars five thousand
dollars
and no no no no then they print money
i think i looked at the cryo the cryo
stuff and also uh the second one
is um uh these dexa scan uh places
um i love that they it's such it's like
literally it's one employee
and uh online booking contactless
payments all that stuff so you basically
have one person who's usually it's
theirs
it's their place uh sometimes they have
kind of a junior person who watches it
while they
while they leave for half the day but
it's very low labor
and it's just the same machine that pays
itself off in the first x uses
um and x can be you know might take one
month might take three months if i take
six months max but
uh these businesses are pretty simple
and uh can do quite well
have you heard of that business called
dexa fit the one they're like guys in a
van
yeah they come to you yeah and you do
the decisions they work in front of like
company buildings usually and they're
like hey
come see you know how fat you are and
then you know you pay 80 bucks and you
go get scanned or 50 bucks and you go
get it they're the best
i go when i look every three months i
would go every three months safe i would
buy like a
10 turn pass or something like that it
was maybe 50 bucks a turn
and you see progress they are so awesome
it's uh i would imagine it's a pretty
expensive machine maybe 100 grand per
van
um they're really amazing i would love
to see what the revenue is and
eventually they bought a
they had a place right across the street
from the uh twitch studio or
you know the studio show that we would
go to and it was like a crappy lobby
with just like a cat scan and you would
sit down in there and then you're out a
few minutes
i love that business i would i'm curious
as to how they do
elaine you ever seen this i think i know
what you're talking about i've never
done it i'm curious with it is it
telling you information you don't know
when you do it the first time
i get that that's a novelty but if
you're doing it every three months
do you not know how your body's been
behaving over those three months
it tells your body fat percentage right
but like don't you know if it like went
up this month well that's
that you want to measure the progress
right so like for example uh i'm working
out right now
my actual weight stays the same because
i'm adding muscle
i'm losing fat and so i'm like [__] this
doesn't i
i want my score to show the progress i
can see it in the mirror and my
trainer's like dude do you need this you
just look in the mirror it's fine
and i'm like yeah that's true but i like
the science of it too i'm like it's 40 i
think it's 45 bucks to go get dexa scam
and uh so me and my brother-in-law we
kind of made a habit out of it and like
we're just like okay we're gonna go get
scanned every three months that's how we
measure our progress
and like you know great we're down three
percent body fat like let's do it again
that we're referring to it's called body
spec so the word body and then
s-p-e-c body spec and sam just so you
know it looks like the price of these
range from between
sixteen thousand and forty-five thousand
dollars so that yeah
that's not that bad and they like
they're in like like a mercedes sprinter
and they have like the car wrap so maybe
a hundred grand total um
i think this is cool i love this company
um i don't know anything about their
numbers but i think
it sounds so neat it's so simple the
distribution for this is also good
because they can partner with gyms so
they partner with crossfits they partner
with uh you know trainers
and they're basically like hey you send
it to client you know you get 20 bucks
out of the 50 buck
like like scan um you know for the for
every first time customer that you send
in
and so they have like kind of a built-in
referral system that makes a lot of
sense
i'm actually shocked to lend that you're
not like bullish on this because
when i go it sounds like shawn and i are
the same when i it's so rewarding like
i'm pretty much working my ass off
literally just to go from like 20 body
fat to like 19.5 percent like
i just think about that number
constantly i think i'm just
not the target demographic at all
because i've always been extremely into
fitness
but i'm intrinsically motivated so i
don't know
you know what i was gonna say though a
partnership opportunity for them is
future fit
because they're already charging people
a month for literally a digital
subscription to a virtual trainer
and you can bundle in a lot of these
other services and things like that
that to me feels like the demographic
because the people i know that do
futurefit
are the people that care about this
stuff they want to see incremental
progress they want to know their score
constantly and they'll pay
i used futurefit so there you go good
job
everyone keeps trying to get me to use
it i'm like i don't need this like
i i just i'm very very competitive with
myself
i have a peloton which you can see in
the back and i've always been a huge
runner
and my mom actually won this like four
years ago
and at the beginning i didn't use it a
lot and now i've been doing a lot more
cycling during the pandemic because i
hate running with a mask
and i've gotten so much better at the
peloton but i'm always trying to beat my
own score i don't need to know i
remove the leaderboard and stuff i don't
care about that but it's it's my own
my own score one of your portfolio
companies is called tempo sean have you
tried the tempo
it's awesome it is so awesome it is so
awesome have you not tried this i
haven't tried it you showed me the
videos if you had it in your garage you
still have it
i bought one okay so elite they
sponsored us so i got paid money
i just used their machine and then i
moved and they freaking took it back i'm
so mad at them like yeah just leave it
let me have it
they took it back after i used it and i
was like on the number one i was at the
time very very
in uh fit into that hit hit stuff and i
was in shape
um and i was like number one in the
category and i kept working my butt off
to do it and i just bought one the other
day i think i paid
eighteen hundred dollars it took eight
weeks to get delivered um
and this for the listeners it's called
tempo fitness or something just google
tempo fit
and it's basically like peloton but for
weightlifting
um and for high intensity interval
training it is so awesome
so addicting i like in building my
workout routine strictly around tempo
it has it's like a mirror like the the
mirror thing so it's freestanding
it's not like tonal where you have to
wall mount it and it has i think 185 or
close to 200 pounds of weights and it's
got these
amazing instructors that do all kinds of
these hit workouts
we had one of the original beta units in
our office and i was pretty much the
only one that used it but i use it all
the time
i don't have room for it now but uh sean
when our office reopens you'll have to
come in and try it i'd love to that's
it sounds pretty good i remember sam uh
the video looked cool i would say that
the
actual design of the box i don't know if
you had like kind of an earlier version
of what
it wasn't as slick as like what a
peloton or mirror and whatnot looks like
it's not entirely slick
but i actually think they're making an
error but but it has a sensor on it so
it like tr it could tell if you're
lifting the weights and it counts it for
you so it's kind of hard to cheat that's
great but
but it's like a cabinet where they store
the weights and i think a lot of people
actually already have the weight so i
wish they would sell it to me just so i
don't have to use their weights
well it uses computer vision to not only
count the reps but it checks your form
so let's say you're doing a curl and
you're only going 80 up it'll call that
out
if you're doing a lunge and your knee is
going over your ankle and so
part of the weight counting rev involves
their own weights
but all the other stuff it's essentially
creating a like a dot matrix of your
body so it's anonymized but it can tell
exactly what your form is
so it's like a real time personal
trainer there plus this
celebrity trainer who's doing the class
for you it's pretty freaking cool
you gotta get one sean they're good it's
it's it's worth it but there is another
downside it's 50
a month for a subscription right they
all are though i think that's crazy
that's so expensive and it's so
expensive i cannot believe that
i think it's way too expensive cheaper
than a gym membership
yeah i know you do that logic yada yada
yo you got my money
i mean i'm paying for it but i still
think it's for the price of a cup of
coffee a day
you could transform your body yeah
by the way it's ten bucks a month so but
think okay think about the value you get
from that
versus essentially in my opinion future
fit is paying for accountability so
you're paying 200
a month for a person on the other end to
like sort of care about you
i get it but like i know what this costs
them i know
like i i already bought this two
thousand dollar machine and like give me
a years free at least
um they don't make a ton of money on the
hardware part they're making money on
the subscription
well look i'd stop using logic on me and
it just let me be angry that currency is
not accepted here we're like a vending
machine
you keep putting it on and you keep
getting it back out
as long as you keep paying for it i'm
okay i'm okay with removing logic
no i'm paying for it another great one
that you guys should look at is our
gotta you guys know right now
we're too famous now we only use free
[__] that people give us we don't pay
for anything anymore
you know how great works the more
popular and rich you get the less you
play for anything so i
at this point i don't pay for anything i
actually stopped giving out my address
because i was getting so much free [__]
and i was like wait
maybe i shouldn't give up my home
address to these like strangers on
twitter
so now i'm like i'm like no thank you
i'm gonna get one of those
celebrity youtuber p.o boxes and be like
you know just send it to my manager
and send it to my partner i always say
like hey i would love to send you x y
and z
and you say yeah i i just gave him ben's
address
like hey will you share right right i
just give him ben's address now i'm like
give ben all the free [__] and they're
like
wait you're not in brooklyn i'm like
yeah yeah i have a house in brooklyn
you can send me all the stuff you don't
want to especially if anybody wants like
women to test stuff send it to me i'll
take it
i'm sure you're you've got you i've seen
your portfolio companies they're badass
you probably have so much great stuff
yeah no follow me at zelby.stubstack.com
z-e-l-b-y it's called three things every
sunday i publish
three business ideas and they're i would
say somewhat well researched and thought
through but uh they're all fun and they
cover
pretty much every topic you can imagine
and then also if you like unsexy
businesses i do a podcast called unsexy
and i just talk to founders building in
super random niches like chemical
marketplaces
or companies that are growing the growth
media for
lab grown meat just super random stuff
but i find it fascinating like our
sister from another mother
honestly when i heard the podcast really
early days i was like oh my god these
are my people
yeah you're great thank you for coming
on um
all right see everyone
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want
travel never looking back
uh